[Music]  my name is britt hume and i've been with  fox news since the first day of 1997.  when we were getting started very few  people thought we would succeed we  didn't have the biggest budget but there  was a fighting spirit that existed there  from the beginning that was contagious i  did not  have sexual relations with that woman  when the clinton lewinsky story broke i  was  planning to start later that year  a new show at six o'clock we didn't have  a uh studio we didn't have a staff we  didn't have much anything my wife who  was then running the washington bureau  said to me you know you really ought to  think about starting your show now do i  call the boss yeah that's right it ought  to start we should start it tonight i  said tonight are you crazy welcome to  washington i'm britt hulman well we did  guess what and  you know i don't know any place i've  ever worked that would have dared to try  that but we did  and that's been part of what set us  apart